4° seulement ce matin en périphérie de
dole cette voiture c'est la maison
d'annie 74 ans et de ses deux vieux
chien clint poupette timimi lausanne une
vie aussi difficile avec moi mais je
m'occupe de vous mais chérie tu laisse
pas tomber
annie et retraités elle touche 850 euros
de pension en juin suite à des problèmes
de voisinage
elle a dû quitter son appartement et n'a
rien trouvé depuis
jusque là les températures étaient
clémentes mais depuis deux jours les
choses ont changé là on sent vraiment le
froid puis même si on s'équipe aux
froides quand on s'endort pour la nuit
je suis obligé de mettre le moteur en
route pour chauffer l'habitacle de la
voiture à l'intérieur parce que les
chiens sur frei pleurs gilles de soin de
sortir de cette situation je n'ai à 6 h
autour d'elle de bonnes âmes s'activent
pour l'aider à mettre du gazole dans son
véhicule ou pour stocker ses affaires
dans des containers mais alors que l'on
tourne ces images la septuagénaire est
frigorifiée
nous lui proposons donc de se réfugier
dans un magasin voisin vous êtes habillé
comment la ville de bezons la boudeuse
dès notre arrivée sans la caméra le
personnel du magasin réagit la
responsable propose annie de choisir des
vêtements chauds qu'elle va lui offrir
les deux vendeuses lui en veux pas du
coup ça c'est ma collègue qui vous l'a
fait madame moi je vous paye les petits
de pair avec les vêtements la
responsable du magasin offre aussi de la
nourriture à annie et les croquettes
pour ses chiens de vrai cadeau de noël
avant de trouver peut-être un logement
chaud